istres la parole est à monsieur jean
bizet pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire c'est le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
je rappelle que les négociations
communautaires sur la politique agricole
commune sont maintenant terminées et
contrairement à ce que le prêt en de la
république et vous même monsieur le
ministre aviez toujours soutenu les
crédits sont fortement en baisse baisse
de 49 milliards dans le cadre du cadre
financier pluriannuel baisse de 1,1
milliard par an pour la france il s'agit
maintenant de décider des règles de
répartition nationale en particulier les
7 milliards et demi d'êtres direct
s'agit donc maintenant de ne pas
fragiliser notre agriculture il s'agit
maintenant de rappeler que l'agriculture
est d'abord d'abord un acte de
production et que la compétitivité de
l'agriculture est un objectif en soi
or en choisissant de surdotées les
cinquante deux premiers hectares d
exploitation vous faites exactement
l'inversé vous déséquilibrer l'ensemble
de l'agriculture française fasse
précisément à nos principaux partenaires
notamment l'allemagne
il ne s'agit pas loin de moi d'opposer
les uns aux autres les types
d'exploitations les filières où les
producteurs
il s'agit simplement de dire que la
baisse des concours publics à
l'agriculture
c'est un fait nous oblige à repenser
notre modèle et nos outils
d'intervention afin de garantir la
pérennité de notre agriculture et de
notre secteur agroalimentaire en termes
d'efficacité et de compétitivité
monsieur le ministre nous craignons que
vos choix finissent par faire perdre sa
vocation économique au premier pilier de
la pac
la prime aux cinquante deux premiers
hectares en est l'illustration parfaite
unique en europe puisque c'est une
décision franco française
elle ne répond pas aux attentes des
producteurs de lait notamment de l'ouest
elle ne résoudra pas davantage les
difficultés de l'élevage
elle générera enfin pour les céréaliers
notamment des distorsions de concurrence
évalué à plus de 100 euros par hectare
sur le ministre quel est donc votre
conception de l'agriculture française
et quand allez vous sortir de la logique
de subventions pour entrer dans celle de
la production et de la compétitivité
économique d'un secteur clé de
l'économie française merci monsieur jean
bizet la parole est un monsieur stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
résidents monsieur sénateurs d'abord je
note une contradiction vous avez parlé
d' aide et ensuite vous nous parlez de
subventions il faudrait savoir si
l'agriculture n'a pas besoin d'aidés de
subventions
c'est un sujet qu'on peut discuter le
deuxième point est contrairement à ce
que vous avez dit et là je vous apporter
des précisions
la première chose c'est que sur les
paiements redistributif c'est à dire la
sueur majoration des premiers hectares
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire
d'autres pays européens vont le faire
mais vous avez parlé de l'allemagne pas
de chance
l'allemagne va mettre en place des
paiements redistributif ça c'est le
premier point
deuxième point vous parlez de
compétitivité et quelle est la vision
que j'ai de l'agriculture dans les
années qui viennent et bien là on a un
vrai débat entre nous vous venez d'un
département la manche où il ya des
producteurs de lait organisées souvent
en gaec si je prends les exemples donnés
par ces grecs autour de 700 800 mille
litres de quota aujourd'hui avec trois
associés si je ne surtout pas les
premiers hectares en rapport au nombre
d'agriculteurs chef d'exploitation qui
sont sur ces grecs le risque de demain
monsieur le sénateur c'est de voir
l'agriculture se faire sans agriculteurs
mon projet à moi c'est de faire
l'agriculture avec des agriculteurs des
éleveurs et des paysans c'est peut-être
ça qui nous différencie et quant à la
question de la compétitivité alors là
réfléchissez deux fois avant de le dire
comme ça parce que la compétitivité de
l'agriculture
elle dépend de la compétitivité des
hommes et des femmes qui sont dans
l'agriculture
et moi je suis allé en afrique du sud
j'étais avec laurent fabius et j'ai
discuté avec le directeur général de
danone
afrique c'est-à-dire pas simplement de
l'afrique du sud j'ai fait le constat
suivant avec lui c'est pas moi qui n'ai
dit c'est lui c'était très intéressant
ils sont 45% du marché du lait en
afrique du sud aujourd'hui et je dis
mais comment vous vous approvisionnez il
me dit nous céder ferme de cinq à dix
mille vaches cinq à dix mille vaches et
jeudi le prix il est de 42 centimes
c'est à dire supérieurs avec ces
organisations de production à celui que
nous avons ici en europe donc sur la
question de la compétitivité la
l'organisation de la production laitière
la productivité du travail lié aux
agriculteurs est un élément monsieur le
sénateur de la compétitivité
et quand on supprime les premiers
hectares je lui ai dit à l'heure la
vision qu'on a c'est d'assurer à notre
agriculture
sa capacité compétitive en même temps de
lui assurer sa diversité et surtout ses
agriculteurs
ces paysans et ses éleveurs donc moi je
n'en pose pas contrairement à ce que
vous faites
au travers de cette sur dotation la
question qui est liée à l'organisation
de l'agriculture et à sa compétitivité
les deux sont parfaitement liés c'est ça
le projet que je défende
merci monsieur le ministre